the hashtag cancel kimmel is trending
after the late night show host passed
has come back to haunt him
in particular it's an interview with
actress megan fox
where she was talking about working with
director michael bay
i was an extra in bad boys too really
and yeah
they said you know michael um she's 15
so you can't sit her at the bar and she
can't have a drink in her hand so his
solution to that
problem was to then have me dancing
underneath the waterfall getting soaking
wet
and that perfectly holds 15 i was in
10th grade
this resurfaced clip of megan now has
the actress setting the record straight
about her transformers director
after social media lit up with outrage
that's sort of a microcosm of how bay's
mind works
yeah well yeah well that's really a
microcosm of how all our minds work but
some
some of us have the decency to repress
those things
and pretend that they don't exist
twitter users fired off quote
this is disgusting why hasn't jimmy
kimmel or michael bay been called out
another solely targets kimmel why is i'm
so sorry that happened to you
something that is beyond his imagination
to say
in a lengthy instagram post megan didn't
address kimmel
but does say she needs to clarify some
details to cast a sinister shadow that
doesn't really belong
megan takes issue with fans claiming
michael bay made her dance in a bikini
and washed his car as part of her
audition for transformers and then
ruined her career when she complained
about him quote when i auditioned for
transformers
i was 19 or 20. i was not made to wash
or work on someone's cars in a way that
was extraneous from the material in the
actual script i was never assaulted or
preyed upon
and what i felt was a sexual manner i
don't think there's anything wrong with
being sexy it's just the problem that
that part was so loud that it muted out
the rest of who i was
hey michaela e.t was on the set for both
transformers movies with megan and
co-star shia labeouf
both rising stars looking young and
eager to learn
they explained what happened while
shooting this make-out scene yeah
michael let us go though for like
for a while for a while for like three
minutes straight well yeah yeah yeah
yeah i slipped him at 50. you didn't
know about that whole scene but thanks
babe
last night bay reposted megan's
statement as well as a shot from her
audition tape
writing she is not washing a car nor in
a bikini
i'm proud to have worked with her and
still am planning on working with her
as for kimmel no comment on that but he
is apologizing after facing even more
backlash
what the hell going on up there that's
jimmy in blackface on comedy central's
the man show
from the early 2000s where he frequently
impersonated nba star
carl malone and oprah winfrey margarite
soft brown stomach protects my knees and
ankles from unnecessary wear and tear
the clips resurfaced after fellow late
night host jimmy fallon apologized for
his snl skit from 2000. what i kept
getting advised was
to just stay quiet and to not say
anything today in a statement to et
kimmel says quote i apologize to those
who were genuinely hurt or offended
by the makeup i wore or the words i
spoke there's nothing wrong my family is
healthy i'm healthy
i just need a couple of months off soon
after announcing he was going on a
pre-planned summer vacation
an audio recording emerged of jimmy
using the n-word
while impersonating snoop dogg on a 1996
christmas album
kimmel now calls sketches like this
embarrassing
and thoughtless but quote i believe that
i have evolved and matured
jimmy is supposed to host the emmys this
fall some wonder if that's in jeopardy
amid the cancel kimmel hashtag